did you know we were over
Have elections for 2 months already
namely on June 6 Thursday6-6-1 Thursday
we are going to vote for the european parliament
this is one of the least popular elections
especially in the Netherlands
especially among the youth looking at you and me
and that's why it is so
important that you will vote on June 6
so whatever you think of the EU
the EU has a lot of impact
on our daily life
it feels like we are eating
the products we use that we order
that we do not pay extra costs
when we do
when we don't
using the euro
everything it may seem complicated to read in
but it is not really
because most parties
You should already know those on the list
they are mainly the largest parties
which we also have on
national and local level
only sometimes the smallest parties are not included
because it is more difficult to the european parlament
to enter
that the Dutch Parliament
so you will especially
see the larger parties that we have in the Netherlands
and whatever you think of the EU
you will have options whether you are 1 other EU
pro EU you have criticism
all those options are on the list
and whatever you think of it
in any case,
the EU is very important
in our daily life
if you live here
Dutch was one of the founders of the European uni
and it now has an awful lot
impact on our lives
about 80% of our laws come from Brussels
so it is very important
that you make your voice heard for the
european elections
for the election of it
european parliament
on Thursday, June 6